hey guys merry here with a gamespot news
update on the witcher 3 it looks like
players won't be getting their weekly
dose of dlc this week instead patches on
its way CD Projekt RED is calling this a
very large patch that will make a number
of changes to the game some of the
biggest changes are as follows a new
alternative optional movement response
mode for Garrels a player's dash for
storing items alchemy components no
longer way garel down multiple sorting
options will now be available for the
inventory dozens of fixes requests
related issues and improved horse
behavior the full patch notes will be
released later this week this will also
be the first Witcher 3 patch to release
on consoles the same time it releases on
PC unfortunately the 16th and final
piece of free DLC will not come out this
week because CD Projekt RED is all hands
on deck right now working to finish and
launch patch 1.07 the final piece of
free DLC will be available next week are
you looking forward to the sweet 16th
and final DLC for the witcher 3 and what
have you thought about all the DLC so
far let me know in the comments below
and for all your gaming news be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot com